leave it to Kanye West to shut down a
whole street in LA we're outside one of
21 Pablo pop-up stores around the world
the folks out here on this one wrap
around the block we got our et instacart
Bay we're gonna set up shop and talk to
the people causing traffic okay how does
this work
Oh open oh great I got help see they
don't just run the store they help look
I think I think we nailed it is it up is
it stable thank you very much welcome
I've ever been on a red carpet before no
this is a is a first for me who are you
wearing uh this is a shirt and some
pants so I take your huge Kanye West fan
I like them you like they're like them
Oh see this is what happens that's
calling a personal hero hero of yours
get them big influence you know what we
do like he like he's changing our
generation confidence we rock dust out
he don't care about nothing else and and
he opened a lot of doors for like no
designers so how long have you guys been
online then 2 a.m. so you scoped out the
website I'm sure do you know what you're
looking for in there yeah I'm getting
like the white shirt and a purple shirt
come and get your Pablo merge step right
up line is moving what are you looking
for in particular do you know uh I'm
trying to get couple long sleeve shirts
couple t-shirts okay maybe a sweater or
two now the news of this pop-up store
only broke this week do you guys have
enough time like save up some money cuz
shirt ain't cheap in there renew that
like this gave you a bunch of drops this
season so we've been getting ready for
weeks so what's your guys to strategy
when you go in there cuz gonna be chaos
so are we going elbows you go at me like
we're tackling stolen elbow security
scary do you know what you're looking
forward you know what you want yeah
pretty much t-shirt yeah assuming cuz
your fans are Kanye your fans of Kim
yeah yeah yeah I'm getting that kimochi
merch oh oh I knew it I felt it I was
like Kim's butt is somewhere around here
I know it so what'd you get everything
shirt t-shirt would a kid I got it for
my nephew's oh and of the year folks and
of the year how long were you guys in
line today
what who do you know how dare you you
know the Kardashians are you related to
them yeah how do you know them as we're
family I know but like cousin I love it
I love it you were the first in line
actually I thought I saw right we all
were first in line we're a group we know
unit we got here at 1045 last night
yesterday yeah so you slept here
definitely grab this all of you Kanye
one okay right here I got a couple of
hat a couple t-shirt cup crew there you
go it's all for you or these are gifts
early Christmas presents a couple gears
couple birthday presents Manning for
myself I'm a collector we're coming to
you guys who wants to be on TV I don't
even know whose chairs these are but I
took them how long have you been here
since 6am okay so I don't know what time
is it now like what like seven hours you
eat just some snacks you know like chips
and stuff like that nothing pack snacks
yeah okay how do you survive being in a
line like there's that long you got ET
into carpet my exclusive whip and what's
going on guys Matt for my TV what did
you uh are you a big easy fan my son of
um I am I'm getting to be what showing
me is he showing you the ways he showed
you the way of Jesus but I'm here for
him I love he wants to get some
merchandise mom of the year am i right
yeah how long have you guys been in line
we got here at about eight o'clock in
the morning okay not too bad what's your
overall impression of Kanye West have
you seen the famous video um yes I have
yeah his impression my impression is
that he's a really interesting guy that
your son's like blushing over there your
sleazy groundbreaker measurable yeah and
a lot of people love him he has more
followers than probably suppose I think
you might be right
alright i walked away with my Pablo
merch which means it's time to get out
of here we're wrapping up this party
like honey said no more parties in LA
good luck everybody I'm out thanks for
watching ET on youtube there's plenty
more great content all you got to do is
click to subscribe